this is so important for me to take
because I'm a handsome man like my
genetics is so freaking strong ladies
you want your kids to look like me and I
just want to know where that comes from
[Music]
so I'm key and today we're gonna be
finding out which African tribe we're
from I'm from Kansas City Missouri
at least that's where the colonizers
brought me the little that I know about
my family background I mostly comes from
my mom's side Oh my dad's side I don't
know much about where it comes from my
dad's last name it is Irish I believe so
like I don't know I don't know if that
has anything really to do anything other
than like they were owned by people from
Ireland or something like that but my
grandfather on my mom's side he always
told me that we were Nigerian and part
Irish too but he also was like a
pathological liar
[Music]
hi my name is Casey James and I'm from
Brooklyn New York so I'm lucky enough to
know like where my ancestors kind of
come from my grandfather and my
grandmother they're both from sure dad
in Tobago
so most of my family have liked
Caribbean roots and my mom was the first
one to come over to United States
so I'm first-generation American
so I was born in Memphis Tennessee but I
spend most of my time growing up in
Arkansas maternally I know a few things
one I know that Williams is obviously a
slave name it's like one of the biggest
slave owners name but I also know my
grandmother's maiden name is blinking
which I know was huge in South Carolina
[Music]
Oh No where I'm from it probably has to
be western Africa because like I'm like
a nerd for history oh I honestly don't
know I feel like it is shrouded in
mystery one time I did this
ancestry project in school and like all
the other kids like oh my family is from
England or my family has direct ties to
Russia or like whatever and it was just
weird for me because I asked so many
people my family and a lot of them
didn't even know and it's kind of sad
cuz like a lot of why people don't have
that that ability to be like yeah this
is where I'm from where I know exactly
where we go and I feel like a lot of
that was stolen for us i text 2-month
was who I think are like they know most
about everything that's happened in our
family in our family history so I texted
them both and here was my eloquent
solicitation for more information on
family history hey um I'm shooting the
video tomorrow for work where I get my
DNA tested to find out which African
tribe I'm from via the new African
ancestry test the either of you guys
know anything about where I family is
from originally the United States were
outside of the United States or any idea
where I folks we're from before Arkansas
any information helps thank you so I
sent that long text to my uncle and his
response
what Conda so like well before I even
get into this I don't like white people
have to do the white people really trace
back their family like because of brutal
slave train all right so I'll rip it
says better bolder blacker choose
African ancestry yes here for all of
this
I just wanna Rolly Rolly Rolly
sounds like a Wednesday night and we
wonder if I knew then we were going to
be the way that we are but they still
have done the things that they did so I
filled out everything I got the package
together I'm not gonna lick this stamp
I'm gonna use a sponge and close this
and I'm ready to find out where my
ancestors were stolen from hi I'm Gina
Paige I'm the president and co-founder
of African ancestry calm so I'm in the
business of being black I love sitting
down with black people
and telling them where they're from and
sharing this transformative information
so I'm looking forward to the crew from
buzzfeed to tell them where their roots
are
hi Ryan
nice - nice to meet you too oh the the
test that you took looks at one branch
of your family tree okay right so you
know you have two parents four
grandparents
eight great-grandparents and it keeps
going back right what we're only looking
at one branch so we looked at your
mother's mother's mother's mother's
mother's line Wow and that goes back 500
to 2,000 years so when we trace paternal
line we use what's called the y
chromosome that's what you inherited
from your father he got it from his
father and his father and his father
well during the history of slavery white
men were having brown babies right more
often so let's say a British slave
holder bah there's a son with an
enslaved Nigerian woman the son's gonna
be black right he's gonna have black
sons who have black sons who have black
sons whether they look like me or you
the Y chromosome goes back to the
British man
so that would like to expose it so right
so it's going to be European not African
and that's no surprise we know that
history right right so white women
weren't having brown babies as often as
white men so that's why we see African
ancestry more often on the maternal line
oh so your results are actually a little
unusual Oh God
and that's because we found matches for
you in several different countries whoa
[Laughter]
but we found your results in four
countries most of which were part of the
mile
one country that we found your ancestry
in has a group of people called the
Jolla people and they are in Guinea the
South today Guinea Bissau so that's a
very - one of the smallest countries on
the west coast of Africa you also we
found your same DNA signature among
people who are Mandinka the Mandinka are
the griot of the culture and the group
Rios are the the keepers of the culture
so through music and song they tell the
history of families in the in the
different Senegalese communities so they
are from Senegal that's cool so the
Mandinka are also known as warriors okay
which leads me to the next group that
you share ancestry with with which is
the Mende Mende the Mende people in
Sierra Leone today okay and the Mende
are known as those who were on the Imus
Todd basically the enslaved Africans on
the ship refused to be captured and they
turn the ship around I've always like
thought back to you like cuz I'm very
good at directions like I can go
somewhere once oh my god I can get back
again just have that innate sense and
thinking about being a warrior I've
always liked consider myself like if I
we lived like in a society where we
didn't have like electronics and like
things only tell us what we're going I
would just be like I gather or a warrior
because I know where I'm going so then
this is crazy because I've never met you
before yeah like five minutes ago right
we didn't plan this no but the last
group that you share ancestry with were
the coastal people in southeastern
Liberia and they were sailors that is
weird
not only were they sailors but they were
very resistant to enslavement and the
British often wouldn't enslave them but
instead would have them navigate the
ships I'm just saying that's really cool
I'm not making this up I'm very excited
to just like to be able to pinpoint
where my people are from and like also
have a lot of historical context of Who
I am as a person
I mean I knew obviously your DNA holds a
lot of like secrets to who you are but I
didn't realize how specific it would be
and I also to like know that these
tribes in these these groups of people
make up my part of my personality or
part of the talents and abilities that I
had there's a level of understanding I
have now that makes me so much more
excited than I ever thought I would have
been so I thank you I was going on hi my
whole family is waiting on these results
mm-hmm I was really excited when I saw
that your people were from Trinidad
because that helps to give us some
variety and to spread the word that yeah
is great to be Trini but guess what it's
great to be from where ever before
Trinidad - sure sure we found your
ancestry in Africa right which is great
okay the first country the group that
you share ancestry with has these secret
societies called poro societies and
they're where men raise boys up they
initiate them into manhood and so
there's this whole set of culture almost
cultural practices almost like a rites
of passage yeah that term name boys go
through in Sierra Leone as they become
men so I really want you to look into
that I'm like there's another theme that
you'll see is connect connects you in
this whole BuzzFeed crew this theme of
resistance yeah because the Temne people
were also resistant to to enslavement
right that rebel spirit I feeling to me
I'm he's even hard for me to work a
nine-to-five
[Music]
like that well there's another group
yeah that you share ancestry with from
my father's side no two groups that you
share ancestry with not just the term
name in Sierra Leone but there's another
group called the Balanta people mm-hmm
and guess what burrata means I don't
know it means those who resist Wow
yeah Portuguese came and colonized this
very tiny country called Guinea Bissau
yeah they were met with a lot of
resistance by the Balanta people right
cuz they weren't having it either Wow if
anyone knows me
everyone knows I'm super rebellious yeah
like naturally you almost can't help it
yeah Wow and say that that's the beauty
of learning the specific groups and
countries that you have connection to
genetically Wow Wow you're changing the
world man okay nice to meet you Kate you
I'm super excited about this okay I
don't know anything about my family we
exist to help you better I understand
who you are yeah that's the only reason
we're here yeah it's because you deserve
to know where your family was before
Mississippi and before Arkansas there
was this disconnection and King you know
that makes us the original victims of
identity theft mmm that's real we're the
very first woman yeah we lost our names
we lost our languages we lost the
freedom to honor our ancestors and our
families were torn apart so if you don't
know your name you can't speak your
language you can't talk to your God and
you don't know where your brothers and
sisters are or who they are
then who how can you know who you are
yeah yeah
so we found your ancestry
people in two countries okay two
countries and the first group that you
share ancestry with those people are
known as nomads hmm you'll find that
they've traveled all across all across
all across West Africa and you'll find
them in probably six or seven different
West African country well they like I
said they were nomads so they moved with
their cattle from place to place they
were often traders because they had to
negotiate in a new place and the women
are considered the most beautiful women
as oh I share maternal aunt
oh really rude in a different country
with the same group so you share
maternal genetic ancestry with the fool
of a few money people mmm it sounds
familiar
yeah so there are Fulani people who live
in Nigeria and that's my ancestry
they're funny people who live in camera
in Mali Senegal and in your country of
Guinea Bissau
oh yeah oh yeah like we're all related
but you all have different people yes
and like the Nomad thing makes so much
sense like every couple months like this
unrest like happens in me I'm like
something has to change and if like
that's just a part of the Nomad into me
and then there's the theme going on here
today and I swear to you you and you
will acknowledge I've never met you guys
yeah know anything about any of you but
this team here there is something about
you all and the Mende and the 10a from
Sierra Leone that's man let me tell you
something I didn't tell the others oh so
Sierra Leone is known for rice
production mm-hmm
so Sierra Leoneans or outstanding rice
farmers the planters in South Carolina
and Georgia at the rice plantations they
specifically got in slave labor from
Sierra Leone because of their ability to
whoa so that's why when when we are
talking about where you are from I was
listening to see if anybody was from
South Carolina or Georgia because we get
a lot of people so that whole Gullah
Geechee culture yeah directly connected
wow people of Sierra Leone whoa and
we've already been through the
resistance the Mende were not having
enslavement the Temne we're not having
enslavement they turn the ships around
that's what I like to hear being quiet
and not saying anything it's just like
wow yeah so I'm gonna welcome you to the
African ancestry family I love this name
is Gracie I don't have my diploma either
it's packed up in a box somewhere but
this is gonna be hanging up somewhere in
my apartment you
great women strong women who I'm so
interested in the doctor Dorothy Height
with Tim nay dr. Maya Angelou whoa
Coretta Scott King Wow in GRE
so there's some you've got some some
women yeah they are a very powerful
ancestry
yeah and that's so cool like hearing
about Coretta Scott King because I know
they like spent a lot of time with mrs.
and that's what Martin Luther King was
assassinated and I was born in Memphis
too so that like a little like tiny
connection it's like super cool to have
and also just hearing about like the
fool of women like I want to like read
up about them and like I don't know just
like learn more and like isn't she
pretty
oh thank you so much for them this is
like my very first DNA test ever and I
just didn't want to take one it was
gonna be like oh your European cuz I'm
like I already know this happen this is
something you need mm-hmm you know this
isn't a novelty this isn't just nice to
know this is this is a need to know and
now you're gonna share you just said you
have to share it yeah